-I am such a fan of your music.
And -- but one thing
I want to get out of the way,
right off the top,
you perform under the name
"Father John Misty."
This is not your name.
Your name is Josh.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And you get asked all the time
how you came up with the name
"Father John Misty,"
and the reality of it
is it´s fairly insignificant.
You didn´t put a lot of thought
into it.
-Yeah, I mean, I can´t imagine
somebody who calls themselves
Father John Misty having, like,
a good reason for anything.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
all my favorite, like, singers,
have kind of show --
you know, show biz names.
-Yeah.
-Like Nina Simone
or Serge Gainsbourg
or, uh, Groban or...
-Yeah. [ Laughs ] When you --
-There´s no way Josh Groban
is his real name.
-No, come on.
-Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-That´s not -- I´m Josh Groban
before that guy is.
-Yeah, he´s not -- next you´re
going to tell me like Tom Cruise
is a real name.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Did you -- When you came up
with "Father John Misty,"
did you say,
"that´s the one"?
Did you know right away or did
you just kind of...
-I was saying that everybody
else who knows me
and cares about me was like...
-Don´t do it?
-"Don´t. Don´t."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah.
-I will say, with the beard
and the hair, you look strangely
more like a Father John Misty
than a Josh.
-Yeah.
I think I look more
like a Dr. Fun.
-Oh, yeah. Was "Dr. Fun"
in the running?
-Oh, yeah, I regret every day of
my life not going by Dr. Fun.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-That would have been fantastic.
-I´d be on "Good Morning
America" right now if I...
[ Laughter ]
-They´d be so happy to have you.
You´d be doing like
a pasta demonstration.
-Oh, yeah, absolutely.
-You´d be cooking something.
-Not with the --
-You have expanded
your horizons, because this
summer you did a movie.
You acted for the first time.
-Yeah.
-How is --
-I look like an actor who´s
in the middle of, like,
a personal crisis right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Right, you were
very successful when
you were super young.
-Right.
-And now you´re going through --
-Exactly.
And now I´m here promoting
my fifth, like,
Marvel X-Babies movie.
[ Laughter ]
Staring into
the middle distance.
Yeah, I was in a movie.
-Did you enjoy --
Now, in the credits,
is it "Father John Misty"?
-No. God, no.
-Okay, good. All right, good.
-We got to, like, take it easy
on the, you know, yeah, on that.
-And you --
I would be a monster
if I Insisted on --
-I´m very happy to hear that.
I would have -- if you´d have
said yes, I would have said
that´s great, but I´m very happy
because it wasn´t great.
-Yeah, I did.
[ Laughter ]
-How did you find -- how do you
feel like you performed
as an actor in the film?
-Pretty good.
I mean, I, uh...I get...
[ Laughter ]
Great.
I do -- I mean, I get asked to
be -- it´s like hipster,
shaman, time-traveling hobo.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Which that sounds --
I would do that.
-Yeah.
-But I finally got given like a
character that I was like, okay,
this is interesting.
I can really do this.
-And what was the character?
-It´s a guy who gets his head
blown off
within, like,
30 seconds of the film.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And so did you --
so you spent a lot of...
-But I, yeah, the first --
well, it was like two days
and the first day --
and this is with real, real
actors like Sterling K. Brown.
-Fantastic actor.
-And Brian Tyree Henry.
Both in it, and I was basically,
like, riffing
the whole first day, which I
didn´t even realize.
Much like right now.
-You mean not doing your lines.
-Spontaneously riffing.
No, yeah, I was --
I didn´t have lines
the first day.
And I went to the director and I
was like, "am I doing okay?"
And he was like..."yeah, you´re
good, you do --
part of making movies is doing
the same thing every time."
-Yeah.
-"And also you can´t, like,
apologize to the person
you just pistol-whipped."
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
"You know, because you feel
self-conscious."
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, okay. And so
the second day was kind of
my big scene. Like, me and these
future bank robbers
blow a hole through a wall,
then we run out and then I yell
something like, "When were you
going to tell us?!"
That was, like, my one line.
-That´s great.
[ Laughter ]
-But the first scene, I, like,
Keystone Cops, just, like,
trip out of the hole
and then I breathed in all this,
like, particle dust
and I´m coughing through my line
and, like, sputtering just like,
"Oh, God, I´m blowing it."
Like, I´m never going to get to
play that time-traveling hobo."
[ Laughter ]
And Sterling and Brian both look
at me like -- and instead of
copping to it
like a decent person,
I pretended like I´m some kind
of genius, like, action hero.
-Oh, wow. [ Laughs ]
-I mean, coughing and tripping
on purpose
is, like, black belt acting.
[ Laughter ]
So I spent the day just, like,
coughing and tripping
through the scenes and the --
it was kind of a law
of diminishing returns
with the feedback.
-Yeah.
-Like, the fifth time it was
like, "Ehh"
-I think...
[ Laughter ]
-Who is -- Father John what?
-[ Laughs ]
-Who is this dude?